[Música]
Hola Soy Gabriel corchean y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magazine quincenal de France 24 en el
que acercamos a América Latina las
historias de medio oriente Esto es lo
que veremos hoy
en Israel frente a la presión de la
población y a manifestaciones históricas
el Primer Ministro Benjamín netañahu
decidió aplazar la reforma judicial
estaremos conectados con nuestros
corresponsales en Jerusalén para
realizar el tema
hace 8 años empezaba la intervención
militar de Arabia Saudita en yemen para
ayudar el gobierno a luchar contra el
grupo Rebelde pero tras años de guerra
que no termina el país está hundido en
la peor crisis humanitaria del mundo
empezó el mes del ramadán un periodo
sagrado para los musulmanes con ayunos
durante el día es la educación de
enfocarse en su fe y de compartir
momentos en familia y entre amigos
empezamos en Israel donde el Primer
Ministro Benjamín metal Yahoo decidió
aplazar temporalmente su polémica
reforma judicial lo hizo ante la presión
de las protestas nacionales que cumplen
tres meses ante la crisis política y
luego de haber despedido a su ministro
de defensa joab Galante la reforma Busca
aumentar El poder del ejecutivo y
legislativo sobre el poder judicial
entre otras cosas daría el parlamento el
poder de evitar de que una ley sea
anulada por el tribunal supremo para
hablar del tema estamos con Federico
Barberena nuestro corresponsal en
Jerusalén Federico Gracias por estar con
nosotros bueno netañahu pospuso el
proyecto de reforma judicial hasta mayo
después de las vacaciones de la Pascua
judía el Primer Ministro realmente dio
Un paso atrás en su proyecto o
simplemente lo está dilatando
la sensación es que con este freno
temporal le atañeo y lo que hizo fue
ganar tiempo y lo inmediato le permitió
calmar al Principal sindicato obrero que
estuvo detrás de la histórica huelga del
27 de marzo permitió que los reservistas
retomen los entrenamientos y que la
oposición se siente e inicie
negociaciones con El Ejecutivo pero
claro los detractores de la Reforma en
ven con desconfianza la voluntad real de
netanyahu de llegar a una reforma
consensuada y han advertido que
cualquier avance unilateral de los
proyectos que conforman la reforma
judicial sepultaría esta suerte de
tregua que se ha trazado ahora pero que
tampoco ha frenado las protestas Y es
que netaniacú ha dejado Claro que tiene
decidido llevar adelante cambios en el
poder judicial eso le permitió también
calmar a sus socios de extrema derecha
que ya están pensando en relanzar esta
reforma a partir de mayo recordemos que
el proyecto de ley que blinda al Primer
Ministro de ser recusado por el poder
judicial ya fue aprobado y que también a
cambio de su apoyo al freno en el
ministro de seguridad el extremista de
benhibir Recibió la aprobación para la
creación de la guardia nacional que
algunos deben se convierta en su milicia
privada
bueno Federico Israel también está
viviendo un aula de protestas históricas
en el país con mucha gente considerando
que el Primer Ministro ha ido demasiado
lejos con su proyecto de reforma
judicial pero Israel está viviendo un
giro significativo con esta revuelta
nacional como también puede afectar a la
división actual
lo más significativo de este movimiento
de su amplitud y su constancia decenas
de miles de israelíes han salido cada
sábado a protestar desde inicios de año
luego se ha extendido a distintos días
de la semana en múltiples ciudades de
Israel y aglutinando de la derecha a la
izquierda política pero un punto de
inflexión no fue la movilización de los
reservistas que son esenciales para
nutrir a las fuerzas armadas de Israel
que en su núcleo permanente no tienen no
es tan extenso Generalmente estos
reservistas se mantienen al margen de
las cuestiones políticas bajo la idea de
que ante todo está servir a la seguridad
de Israel pero cuando cientos de ellos
anunciaron que no iban a asistir a sus
entrenamientos se despertaron las
alarmas sobre cómo podría afectar esto a
la seguridad del estado en cuanto a esa
división la fractura en el tejido social
no es total pero sí ha abierto un debate
entre y una división entre los israelíes
más seculares y liberales y aquellos que
son de sectores más conservadores y
Ultra religiosos Y estos últimos en los
últimos días han comenzado también a
mostrarse en contra manifestaciones
bueno y los palestinos con ciudadanía
israelí representan alrededor del 20% de
la población pero no participan de las
protestas porque
porque en su gran mayoría no se sienten
en representados por
manifestaciones que ven como mayormente
judías ignorando para ellos la
discriminación histórica a la que se ha
visto sometida a La minoría árabe va
también por una cuestión simbólica los
manifestantes van a estas
manifestaciones con las bandera que
tiene las estrellas de David cantan el
himno israelí y abrazan la participación
de militares que entre los árabes como
mínimo generan desconfianza aunque los
manifestantes advierten que un cambio
que la reforma judicial va a afectar a
las minorías para los palestinos con
ciudadanía israelí para muchos de ellos
la Corte Suprema No ya les ha fallado en
el pasado no les representa y tampoco
las consignas de esas marchas que
olvidan para ellos la el fin el pedir el
fin de la ocupación israelí en los
territorios palestinos solo lo han hecho
un grupo minoritario de activistas en
estas protestas de ahí surge también la
principal crítica de los palestinos
hacia las protestas que cuestionan si
esa democracia que los israelíes dicen
tener que se pierda se puede conjugar
con un estado que mantiene la ocupación
y las políticas represivas hacia los
palestinos Muchas gracias Federico
seguimos en Israel Porque mientras gran
parte de la población protesta contra su
gobierno y lucha por la democracia los
palestinos siguen siendo objetos de sus
políticas de aparte en Jerusalén este
ocupado las demoliciones de estructuras
palestinas se han disparado bajo la
nueva coalición extremistad en itañahu e
incluso podría seguir durante el mes del
ramadán rompiendo con la línea de los
últimos años de evitar esto derivos en
el mes sagrado musulmán se estima que
20.000 casas pales chinas están en
riesgo de demolición nuestros
corresponsales Yanira Gómez Muñoz y
Federico Barber ena tienen la historia
zacarilla camina sobre la que iba a ser
su casa una estructura de dos viviendas
para su familia recién destruida por
excavadoras israelíes
queríamos construir nuestra vida aquí
dar un paso más pero la municipalidad no
lo aprobó y pedimos permisos de
construcción pero nos rechazaron de
todas las formas posibles
las autoridades israelíes justifican las
demoliciones por falta de permisos pero
casi nunca se les otorgan a palestinos
de Jerusalén este que se ven forzados a
edificar sin papeles
además si reciben una orden de
demolición y no destruyen sus
estructuras el gobierno les cobra el
trabajo zacarilla y su tío empezaron a
demoler y aún así la municipalidad les
envió dos maquinarias generándoles una
deuda de 30.000 dólares
lo demuli con mis propias manos enviamos
fotos a la municipalidad y no dijeron
nada de que vendría de nuevo porque no
les gustó
aunque las demoliciones son prácticas
regular han aumentado bajo el nuevo
gobierno israelí de extrema derecha en
solo tres meses se han producido la
mitad de los derribos de 2022 según
indica la oficina de la ONU para asuntos
humanitarios
las demoliciones resultan en familias
perdiendo su lugar de residencia el
acceso a sus medios de vida y a
servicios básicos casi 150 palestinos de
Jerusalén este han sido desplazados más
de la mitad son niños
con ese miedo malviven los habitantes de
yavel mukaber donde las autoridades
amenazan con destruir 132 viviendas es
el caso inminente de feras y su familia
que por cinco años construyeron un hogar
en tierras de su abuelo
en toda esta área Residencial Que está
debajo de esta calle han recibido avisos
de demolición
la posibilidad de ver caer tu casa la
casa de tus sueños de tu familia en la
que viviste durante años es un
sentimiento muy doloroso para no ver sus
posesiones entre las ruinas la familia
desalojado la casa como muchos denuncian
que esta política busca echarlos de la
ciudad no permitir las construcciones en
un acto para reducir la presencia árabe
en Jerusalén quieren impulsar la
expansión de la existencia judía e
israelí para alcanzar los objetivos de
los extremistas judíos
sin otro lugar al que ir feras piensa
resistir tanto él como sus vecinos
esperan Evitar que las luces de esta
colina sean apagadas
hace 8 años Arabia Saudita comenzó una
operación militar en yemen para ayudar
al gobierno en su lucha contra el grupo
Rebelde hutchi apoyado por Irán en una
guerra que había comenzado un año antes
de esta intervención ahora el conflicto
se ha estancado con la multiplicación de
grupos armados y el país vive la peor
crisis humanitaria del mundo sin
esperanza de una pronta salida vemos más
en el siguiente informe
es una minoría chiquita marcaron los 8
años de la intervención de Arabia
Saudita su país el más pobre de medio
oriente salieron a las calles de Sana
para pedir el fin de la presencia
militar Saudita la guerra en yemen
empezó en 2014 y enfrenta a los Rebeldes
chiguitas judíos apoyados por Irán por
las fuerzas gubernamentales lideradas
por sunitas tras la toma de la capital
sana por los Rebeldes a principios de
2015 una coalición de Estados encabezada
por Arabia Saudita intervino a petición
del presidente con el fin de Reinstalar
el gobierno reconocido
internacionalmente desde entonces el
conflicto se extendió a todo el país y
ha provocado la muerte directa de al
menos
377.000 personas el reino Saudita impuso
un bloqueo marítimo y aéreo a las
fronteras de yemen lo que ha dificultado
la llegada de recursos a la milicia pero
también la llegada de la ayuda
humanitaria para los civiles según
Naciones Unidas jamás un conflicto había
provocado una crisis humanitaria de tal
tamaño en el mundo más 20 millones de
personas sufren de inseguridad
alimentaria ahora el restablecimiento de
las relaciones diplomáticas entre las
potencias involucradas en el conflicto
Irán y Arabia Saudita podría facilitar
las negociaciones de paz Aunque el país
Sigue estando lejos de poder salir de la
guerra empezó el ramadán el mes sagrado
del islam en estos 30 días los
musulmanes oran ayunan durante el día de
manera rigurosa y celebran Pero qué es
exactamente el ramadán y Qué representa
para los musulmanes
el ramadán es el noveno mes del
calendario islámico el más sagrado para
los musulmanes comienza con la aparición
de la luna creciente razón por la cual
su fecha cambia cada año en esta época
el Ángel Gabriel según los musulmanes se
le apareció al profeta Mahoma y le
reveló el Corán el libro sagrado del
islam los musulmanes ayunan para
conmemorar esta revelación el ramadán
viene de la palabra árabe ramadá que
significa quemar de ahí también el
sentido de Purificación que se hace de
los pecados el ramadán es uno de los
cinco pilares del islam los preceptos
fundamentales de esta religión que
observan los musulmanes en este periodo
los musulmanes se acercan a su Dios a la
y lo hacen a través del ayuno no comen y
no beben durante todo el día y en la
noche Se reúnen para romper juntos el
ayuno con grandes platos típicos los
musulmanes también están invitados a
actuar de forma desinteresada y a evitar
mentir o pelear y abstenerse de tener
relaciones sexuales este año el ramadán
terminará el 21 de abril con tres días
de fiestas Para rezar y celebrar el fin
del ayuno en América Latina la comunidad
musulmana es minoritaria pero está
presente en varios países Argentina es
el país con mayor número de creyentes
cuenta con 400.000 musulmanes esta
comunidad también está presente en
Venezuela guayana Brasil y surinam entre
otros varios países llegamos al final de
esta edición de Expreso de oriente
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos y los
invito a enviar sus comentarios a las
redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web Franz 24.com